it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week the action-packed wall
running Titan Manning online multiplayer
titanfall slams into stores with all its
glory
from the devs that brought you call of
duty never has an FPS been so hyped nor
looked so much like a michael bay film
get in the pilot seat march 11
did you ever think to yourself hey my
life is pretty good and I like to play a
game that takes away all my pride and
reminds me to feel bad about myself well
you're in luck the stunningly brutal
Dark Souls 2 comes out to one shot
you're well trained warrior and remind
you that even with your new shield
you're still garbage at the game well
you're so close to that bonfire
he's all your souls March 11
also this week ps4 and PC get an intense
for player archery combat platformer
with cower fall ascension play two
player co-op or take on three of your
friends and a multiplayer battle arena
with so much badass arrow death you'd
swear you were morana run like that dogs
you aw shoot arrow hit arrow March 11
and finally 3d s just gets the cutest
little game this week featuring oil
painting watercolor and cran like
designs with Yoshi's new island oh it's
so darn cute I just might die
collectorate stars to make your ship fly
right through balloons on Yoshi's bud or
a turret enough of that collect some
coins escort a baby mario and eat
enemies to make eggs that act as
adorable projectiles the cuteness begins
March 14 want a mana Titan but don't
have the budget we'll be giving away 10
copies of titanfall for xbox one on
Tuesday March 11th at 4pm during crows
weigh-in check out gamespot com for more
details release dates are based on
retailer listings and are subject to
change you can see you next week